The main things we're going to learn in this class:
the first two units, we'll focus on symmetric cryptography and it's applications.
Symmetric cryptography means both parties have the same key.
So if we have two people: Alice and Bob--
in cryptography we almost always talk about Alice and Bob--
it's not clear why, but, they're useful people to talk about
and they apparently have lots of secret messages to send between each other--
and they want to send messages.
They want to know that they couldn't be intercepted
by some eavesdropper listening on the channel.
In symmetric cryptography we assume that they both start knowing the same key,
and they can use that same key for both encryption and decryption,
we'll see more of what that means soon in this unit.
What we'll do in units 3 and 4 is introduce asymmetric cryptography,
as well as some applications,
and asymmetric cryptography is also known as public key cryptography.
And the key difference between symmetric and asymmetric cryptography
is that the keys used to encrypt and decrypt can be different.
So, our message gets encrypted, it means there's some function that takes a message
and a key produces some encrypted message--which we call ciphertext.
In symmetric cryptography, the decryption uses the same key.
In asymmetric cryptography, the decryption uses a different key,
and if the keys are different and unrelated, that means you can reveal one of the keys without revealing the other key,
and that's the power that asymmetric encryption gives us,
and we'll see lots of interesting ways to use that.
And in units 5 and 6, we'll look at protocols
that use both symmetric and asymmetric cryptography to solve interesting problems.
The reason most interesting protocols combine both of these
is because asymmetric cryptography tends to be very expensive--
you need big keys, you need lots of mathematics--
to do asymmetric cryptography--lots of computation.
Whereas symmetric cryptography can be very efficient.
So that's why most interesting protocols--
like the one we saw for accessing a secure website--
involve both symmetric and asymmetric cryptography.